the fellows caelers this chair minute
peppers with caruso and frs crumble osho
neural network beast image classifiers
its able to correctly identify object
and images en there necklace more and more
pervasive scientist' it the university
of de bingo
decided to embark on a project to learn
more  about the inner workings of die is
networks
13 question was water daily work
similarly tissue mens
regalia nou when efteling this is with
rising the in a were kings of 10 euros
late this is a research field on
its own a flight report on it to you
every now and then
en we talked about some time but papers
on this
met more to come the thief and two would
be to this free garde in a were kings
of things euro network
in other words to treat it like a black
box at least
temporise het  becomes like so min x en
clip let's have looked at an exam of
en in this example a test subject xabi
nam other than this cat
here we have bang driver networks
that hasbeens friend to the  classical
energienet peeters et
ent so few mens discrete is successfully
identified at altra ciconio network
architecture and most famous now all
words to great game version of de
simkaart
de euro networks are still quite comfod
en dat is so get some view mens photos
with still nothing too  crazy go and drank
here well leslocation led of the cat role
charlie sheen and would link much
further and identifying the map
denyo networks this is even marshall toe
when only give and the edges of the
match
however when looking at a heavily such a
sentence  in export the texture of an indian
elephant
more in adwords there five continents
direct cash
where sammy mens photo
yes we have left here it may be that so
postelmans miro networks inc
more in terms of textures die chips
les tess that hypothesis step number of
india a  elephant
this is correctly identified nou cat
dog and quickly identify and now
code onto your papers a cat with an
elefan texture
and there we go ahead rage  elephant
texture is still got to humans
bad is an elephant then came bon giorno
niro networks after looking samora t
problem
mt that the most common canboli show neuro
network architecture city became strange
because die imagenet ttz vesely about fabio
textures over chips that is fundamentally
different to  how i feel and spank
this is how we know try to remedy this problem
is this problem airoh miro
networks not with the think like you human being
with
something motionless research wie might find something
you for nationwide so good who
creates it dtz dat which senior network
it better understanding of chips
well that's great question and one
possible  to
better set and one star transfer and each
of these images
this is us' follows beacons something wps the
textures with the chips
arm of the guts  t intact the authors
colette de stylized image with peter set
and hef mee this publicly available for
every way this new details edwin modal
rate duo network to image the better
understanding of chips
food and bring get closer to him and
thinking let's take a look at this
review gillet
celestial katori slot and shere khan's de
surprice my training and your network
architecture bij de neem res net 50
jointly under regular and stylized
energienet daten set
after a little fine-tuning de he found
to remarkable fix was de with all in
your network
nou  see is mercy molitor view mens who
ever blue square without right min
he received king is texture beast with the
million euros networks that we note that
erin square shrimp
much closer to the shape and thinking of
you mens you should syndicate this we de law
circles
oh god dan two years papers office chair
the new your network of zo oud
performs the old ones
in terms of accuracy devolo scholars
this is research at i  ts finest die offers
x-plore the interesting guide the air and
look grab em up and may think ii enjoy
this episode en je video dat the bunch of
these videos a man of
two dollars please consider supporting
gaaswand page you on this website gets
more  independent and create better
videos for you cant find a set page
of dot com slash
then minute pepers or just click the link
in the video description tag for watching
and for your generous support and i'll
see you next time